عدت إلى شوارع الرياض لأسأل
السعوديين عن الرئيس ترامب ومن
يجب أن أقابله ، لكن الرجل الذي
قابلتُه بشأن نفس السؤال
قبل عامين كان سيفوز ، أخبرتك
عن برنامجه التلفزيوني أنه يُظهر لي تقريرنا
من الخلف  إذن هذا أنت ، نعم ،
هذا هو ابنك وأنت الذي
قال إن دونالد ترامب سيفوز
وأنت على حق ، أخبرني أنه فخور جدًا لدرجة
أنه غرد على ترامب رابطًا
للتقرير مثل برنامجه ، نعم
اليوم أكثر من ذلك بقليل
الحذر منا  الرئيس بصراحة ، إنه صريح جدًا ،
هل هذا جيد ، الناس مثله ،
الناس في الشعب الأمريكي ، من الذكاء
أن أكون مرة واحدة لذا انتخبوه ،
سألته إذا كان السعوديون يحبونه نعم ولكن ليس في
كل شيء يبدو أحيانًا
سياسيًا والصحافة والفلسطينيين
لا.  أختلف معه ، فأنت لا
توافق على الشيء الفلسطيني ، نعم ،
حول جعل القدس
عاصمة لإسرائيل تمامًا الثانية التي يجب
أن تكون من مليون إلى طلقة واحدة ، هناك
سبعة ملايين وسبعة ملايين شخص يعيشون
هنا في ريو وهو يسير في الشارع
مرة أخرى  الرجل الوحيد في هذه المدينة الذي
قال قبل عامين إن دونالد ترامب
سيفوز بالرئاسة
وها هو كذلك ، هل يطلق عليها الآن أنا أرى
شخصًا آخر أعتقد أنني أعرفه هل تحدثت
إليكم هنا منذ عامين ، لا بأس
ولكن مهلا  لقد كسرنا الجليد الذي
يحبه معجبه في هولي ترامب في حديثه الصريح ، لكن
قرار القدس كان بمثابة صدمة بالنسبة له لأنه
يحتاج حقًا إلى أن يُدار
بطريقة مختلفة.
كرئيس
للرد ، لقد أحبوا أنه جاء مع
عائلته وأحب أنه تحدث عن رأيه أنهم
أرادوا شخصًا كان حليفًا أكثر موثوقية
من أوباما وبالنسبة لراكب هارلي
يشعر أنهم حصلوا على أفضل جزء من
هذا في لحظة هذا  العلاقة
مع وضع إيران في مثل هذه الزاوية
والانكشاف على أن هذه هي الدولة التي
تفعل كل هذه
[الموسيقى] الرهيبة ،
فهو ليس وحيدًا. ترامب لديه نقاط أكثر
مما يخطئ هنا ، الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية هي رقم واحد في
العالم وإذا حققنا نجاحًا  العلاقة
معها حتى نتحسن الآن ، ظلت Trumble a
America جزءًا من السعوديين سريع
التطور في الرحلات المستقبلية في تعامله مع
مخاوفهم الإقليمية